Aujourd'hui, on commence
par une petite question :
Comment s'appelle
cette actrice française
qui joue dans le dernier James Bond
au côté de Daniel Craig ?
Oh, facile !
Laura.
Non, non, c'est pas Laura, c'est...
Je réfléchis ! Je réfléchis !
Eva ?
C’est ?
C'est ?
Un trou de mémoire !
Ça arrive à tout le monde.
Alors d'où viennent-ils ?
Comment se creusent-il ?
Je vous explique tout ça aujourd'hui.
Attention au trou.
Avant de vous expliquer ce qui se passe
dans notre cerveau
quand nous avons un trou de mémoire,
rappelons rapidement
comment elle fonctionne, cette mémoire.
J'espère qu'il va s'en souvenir.
La mémoire est une fonction
de notre cerveau
qui nous permet de capturer, de conserver
et de restituer une information.
Lorsqu'un souvenir
se fixe dans notre mémoire :
une image, une scène, un mot, un son, une odeur,
on dit qu'il se consolide.
À ce moment-là,
des signaux électriques passent
d'un neurone à l'autre.
Un réseau neuronal se dessine,
c'est une sorte de route qui peut relier
plusieurs zones de notre cerveau.
Quand on cherche à restituer un souvenir,
on active ce réseau.
Les neurones se réveillent
et se réactivent entre eux.
Seulement parfois, il arrive que ça bug.
C'est le cas lorsqu'on est victime
d'un trou de mémoire.
Le nom de l'actrice,
vous l'avez ?
Toujours pas ?
Ah, ça y est, je l’ai !
Adèle Exarchopoulos.
Non !
Où en étais-je déjà ?
Ah ! La mémoire.
Je devrais plutôt dire :
les mémoires.
Les scientifiques en distinguent cinq,
situés dans différentes zones du cerveau.
On distingue d'abord
la mémoire de travail.
Elle se trouve ici.
C'est celle que l'on sollicite pour
retenir momentanément une information.
Elle ne reste pas très longtemps,
juste le temps d'accomplir la tâche.
Par exemple,
un nouveau numéro de téléphone
que l'on va composer,
une minute plus tard, moins parfois,
on est généralement
incapable de s'en souvenir.
Mais dans ce cas précis,
il ne s'agit pas d'un trou de mémoire,
car votre cerveau n'a
pas stocké cette information.
On parle de trous de mémoire
quand l'information a été consolidée
dans la mémoire à long terme qui se trouve,
précisément là, dans l'hippocampe.
Ce petit organe,
situé au cœur de notre cerveau,
agit comme un véritable chef d'orchestre.
Les signaux électriques partent d'ici
vers les neurones pour imprimer
et donc stocker nos souvenirs.
On distingue quatre mémoires à long terme.
L'une d'elles sert à stocker
toutes nos connaissances générales :
les tables de multiplication,
Paris est la capitale de la France,
c'est la mémoire sémantique.
Ensuite, il y a celle qui emmagasine
les événements passés de notre vie
un examen, la naissance de nos enfants,
un voyage.
C'est la mémoire épisodique,
elle est liée à nos émotions.
La mémoire procédurale,
elle, nous permet de faire du vélo
sans avoir à se poser de questions.
Enfin, nous possédons une mémoire
perceptive,
c'est la mémoire de nos sens.
Grâce à elle, on se souvient des visages,
des bruits, des odeurs.
C'est la fameuse madeleine de Proust.
J'adore les madeleines.
Lisa, Lauréna...
Je sens que je brûle.
Et maintenant, vous êtes incollable
sur le fonctionnement de la mémoire,
je vous explique ce qui se passe lorsque
vous êtes victime d'un trou de mémoire.
Contrairement au numéro de téléphone
qui n'a pas été stocké dans le cerveau,
les informations qui nous échappent
ont été enregistrées
dans l'une de nos mémoire à long terme.
Elles sont donc bien présentes ici
mais pour différentes raisons,
on éprouve des difficultés à les retrouver.
Le meilleur exemple, c'est le nom de
cette comédienne que l'on ne retrouve pas.
On visualise son visage,
on entend sa voix.
Il est stocké
quelque part dans notre mémoire.
Mais rien à faire,
il ne veut pas sortir.
L'oubli peut durer quelques secondes,
plusieurs minutes ou même se prolonger
durant des heures.
Les scientifiques ont baptisé ce phénomène
très intrigant
“TOT”,
T.O.T.
“The tip of the tongue”.
Littéralement :
“Le bout de la langue”.
Les spécialistes de la mémoire pensent
que ce bug correspondrait à une difficulté
d'accès à l'information plus qu'à
un véritable problème de mémoire.
Notre cerveau aurait parfaitement
identifié l'information recherchée,
le nom de la célébrité,
mais il ne parviendrait pas à obtenir
sa formulation sonore.
Alors, que faire quand ça vous arrive ?
Je vous rassure,
il existe des astuces pour tenter
de faire remonter
l'information à la surface.
Par exemple, rechercher des éléments de
contexte : se rappeler le passage d'un film
pour retrouver le nom de l'actrice
ou parcourir l'alphabet
pour mettre le doigt
sur la première lettre de son prénom.
C'est ce que je fais.
S'il s'agit d'un titre de chanson,
on peut aussi fredonner
l'air pour le retrouver.
La Macarena ! Bingo !
Mais ça ne marche pas à tous les coups.
Dans ce cas, il est inutile de s'acharner.
Il n'est pas rare que le mot mystère
resurgisse au bout de deux ou trois heures
alors qu'on est complètement passé
à autre chose.
Plus surprenant,
les trous de mémoire peuvent parfois
porter sur des actions
que nous effectuons quotidiennement.
Le meilleur exemple, c'est quand on oublie
le code de notre carte bancaire.
Alors si, comme moi,
votre carte bancaire a déjà été avalée,
voici deux petites astuces
qui vous éviteront un nouveau déboire :
Rendez la pratique de votre code
plus consciente,
par exemple
énoncez les chiffres dans votre tête
lorsque vous les composez.
Dans votre tête,
pas à haute voix.
Ou bien, associez les chiffres de votre code
à d'autres connaissances
déjà bien ancrées
dans votre mémoire.
Par exemple, pour le code
1, 3, 7 , 5. 13, 75.
Pensez au départements :
Bouches du Rhône, Paris.
Si en plus il faut se souvenir
des départements, là c'est pas gagné.
Ah ! Il y a un sujet
qui revient fréquemment.
On entend souvent dire que l'abus d'alcool
peut entraîner une perte de mémoire.
C'est le fameux black out.
En fait, c'est un abus de langage.
Alors, bien sûr,
après une soirée trop arrosée,
on peut avoir du mal à se souvenir
de ce que l'on a fait la veille.
Ça n'a rien de glorieux.
Mais ce n'est pas
la mémoire qui fait défaut.
C'est seulement
l'absorption d'alcool qui empêche
la formation de nouveaux souvenirs.
Je m'explique.
Lorsqu'une information est captée
par notre cerveau,
celle ci va d'abord
être intégrée dans la mémoire de travail.
La mémoire à court terme.
Pour être enregistrée,
l'information doit être transférée
dans la mémoire à long terme.
C'est ici que l'alcool produit son effet.
Consommé à l'excès,
il empêche le transfert
des informations, de la mémoire de travail
à la mémoire à long terme.
Alors petit bémol tout de même :
la consommation excessive
d'alcool peut aussi entraîner
de graves intoxications,
avec des conséquences parfois incurables
sur le cerveau et sur la mémoire.
Donc, vous connaissez la chanson.
L'alcool, c'est avec modération.
Alors, faut-il s'inquiéter
de ces trous de mémoire ?
Pour certaines personnes
chez qui ça arrive régulièrement,
c'est une vraie source d'inquiétude.
“Où ai-je mis mes clés ?”
“Mon porte monnaie ?”
“J'oublie tout le temps !”
Rassurez vous, en général,
quand on est conscient
d'avoir des trous de mémoire,
c'est qu'on n'est pas malade.
Les gens qui souffrent de perte de mémoire
pathologique ne s'en rendent pas compte
dans pratiquement 99% des cas.
Dans le cas de la maladie d'Alzheimer,
par exemple, la perte des souvenirs
est liée à la perte de neurones
ou de connexions entre eux.
Contrairement au sentiment de mots
sur la langue, il ne s'agit pas
d'une interférence dans le réseau,
mais de sa dégradation.
Le réseau est incomplet, fragmenté.
D'ailleurs, ces pertes de mémoire
prennent une autre forme :
On oublie le chemin
pour rentrer à la maison ou l'existence
d'un objet plutôt que son emplacement
ou le nom de ses proches.
Elles sont très handicapantes
car elles rendent le quotidien
beaucoup plus difficile pour la personne
et pour ses proches.
Ça y est, je l'ai : Léa Seydoux.
Dix minutes pour trouver,
c'est pas trop tôt.
J'espère
que vous avez apprécié cette vidéo.
Si vous avez déjà oublié
certains passages,
vous pouvez toujours la revoir
afin de bien la mémoriser.
Sinon, vous pouvez mettre un pouce bleu
et vous abonner à la chaine.
Et n'oubliez pas, à très vite,
chers Épicurieuses et Épicurieux.